comme chaque année l'église de saint
germain l'auxerrois de paris accueille
des dizaines de fidèles entre ses murs
pour célébrer la naissance du christ
mais ce vendredi soir en lieu et place
de l'eau bénite c'est du gel
hydroalcoolique qu'on trouvait les
visiteurs
toute personne qui vient qui rentre
d'abord on doit porter le mas doit
ensuite est à voir du gel ensuite en sus
ils vont s'asseoir et pour la communion
ils communient dans la main il n'y a pas
de baiser de paix notre seule donne la
paix comme cela il ya donc aucun contact
même les chanteurs les enfants qui vont
chanter chante avec hamas pour être suez
sont bien écarté pour être sûr de ne pas
transmettre mais sont tous testés
négatifs on est cinq donc on sera 5
demain aussi voilà on est en petit
comité il est pas question de se
retrouver avec des amis
voilà avec les gens beaucoup de gens de
l'extérieur je sais que le coc vie des
prisons après j'avoue que j'évite donc
d'y penser toute la journée h24 parce
que sinon je pense que je serai beaucoup
trop stressant des festivités de fin
d'année sous la menace de mikron alors
pour passer les fêtes en famille les
français se sont fait tester en masse ce
vendredi le pays a enregistré plus d'un
million de tests pcr et antigénique un
record depuis le début de la pandémie
malheureusement accompagné d'un autre
chiffre plus de 94 milles contamination
ont été enregistrés en 24 heures en
france un cadeau de dernière minute dont
les professionnels de santé se serait
bien passé dans les hôpitaux la vague
omicron fait envisager le pire
actuellement nous avons 12 et de
réanimation d'ouvert et quatre lignes du
vc unité de surveillance continue dû
fermer pour prendre des personnels
deux lits de surveillance continue
pendant cette période de noël nous avons
à l'heure actuelle
cette passion qu vide qu'ils sont
tous sont vaccinés et qui sont des
copies qui sont graves dont pas parce
que dans les stations il y en a six qui
sont intubés ventilé face à un risque
réel de paralysie du pays le
gouvernement a convoqué un conseil de
défense sanitaire lundi prochain suivie
d'un conseil des ministres il y sera
notamment question des règles
d'isolement et de surveillance
possiblement adapté aux variants omicron
[Musique]